la carrière ancienne aide soignante
auteur du livre le scandale des ehpad
aux éditions hugo new life
bonjour et la carrière merci de répondre
à nos questions qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la vie' rendu ce matin par la
défenseure des droits claire hédon
bonjour et bien bonjour à tous et toutes
alors pour ma part je suis très contente
que madame aidons et enfin émis ce
rapport elle et tous ses collaborateurs
des sûr car ça fait plusieurs années
maintenant que nous dénonçons ce de
maltraitance institutionnelle est
aujourd'hui le coup vite il ne fait que
relever la maltraitance institutionnelle
que vivent nos aînés en ehpad et ça l'a
même en fait s'ils voulaient le colis de
la même aggravée donc ces gens voient
ces atteintes
elle ne sont pas uniquement des
conséquences de la crise ducobu de 19
elle révèle d'un dysfonctionnement plus
anciens c'est ça oh oui c'est bien
dysfonctionnements qui date depuis des
années et on a beau le démon si on a
l'impression que rien ne bouge
en fait les résidents aujourd'hui ils
sont contraints de vivre au rythme un
rythme effréné des soignants chaque jour
et ils subissent en fait ils ont plus de
liberté
ils ont plus de liberté la liberté de
vivre la liberté de recevoir la liberté
de plein de choses de même de ne
serait-ce que de pouvoir aller aux
toilettes
ils sont beaux ils sont ils arrivent ils
sont souvent continent ils deviennent un
continent parce que ben pour aller
toujours plus vite mais on doit mettre
des protections mixer des repas il ya
plein de choses qui fait que l'on se
concentre sur la rapidité du soin mais
pas sur le besoin du résident en clair
et dont la défenseure des droits énumère
60 recommandations dans son rapport pour
améliorer la liberté des résidents
quelles sont les réformes engagées par
le gouvernement pour permettre
d'améliorer cette situation
aujourd'hui je les connais pas vraiment
ses réformes là parce que si vous voulez
on n'est pas tellement en tant que
j'utilisais mon erreur
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire qu'est ce
que vous voulez vous la priorité
aujourd'hui c'est d'augmenter le nombre
de soignants en ehpad et augmenter le
salaire des soignants le revaloriser
parce que sinon les salariés ne restent
pas ne restent pas parce que c'est un
rythme effréné
on a l'impression d'être maltraitant
alors qu on fait au mieux c'est
l'institution qui nous rend maltraitante
parce qu'on est obligé de toujours aller
plus vite plus vite plus vite mais pour
aller plus vite il faut sacrifier
certaines choses et ces choses là c'est
des choses qui sont primordiales pour
nos aînés et surtout belle la priorité
la priorité aujourd'hui c'est augmenter
le nombre de soignants par résident et
vous avez le voisin allemand qui part
dont un qui ont le double des effectifs
qu'on a aujourd'hui actuellement c'est
quand même scandaleux qu'on puisse se
dire comme france on n'y arrive pas quoi
est ce que ce rapport peuvent faire
évoluer les choses selon vous mais en
tout cas il va faire avancer les choses
certainement ce sera toujours mieux que
rien j'ai envie de dire c'est que les
choses continuent et que on essaye de se
faire entendre au mieux si on en est
arrivé à faire bouger les défenseurs des
droits c'est que positif j'ai espéré
est ce qu'il ya des actions qui sont
prévues prochainement pour vous faire
entendre
bella avec le co vide malheureusement
mais on peut pas trop se mobiliser mais
on veut pas prendre de risque et le peu
de soignants qui a il travaille déjà sur
place on peut pas leur demander de lui
d'aller manifester c'est à dire si les
soignantes qui a le peu qui reste à y
vont manifester il y aura plus personne
auprès des résidents c'est c'est
compliqué quoi merci pour votre
témoignage et la carrière je rappelle
que vous êtes ancienne aide soignante en
et page 6 toujours et sans doute que
vous êtes toujours dans quatre
soignantes on n'est pas pardonné mois et
auteur du livre
vandal des ehpad aux éditions hugo diot
life